Hello Freak bitches.
That's deep.
That is deep.
This is going to be hurtful to a lot of people.
A lot of people listening to this right now,
very upset,
very triggered.
You asked earlier why,
why the postmodernists don't like blunt speech?
Yeah,
well that's why man,
you know,
it's like the truth is something that Burns,
it burns off deadwood and people don't like having their dead wood burned off
often because they're like 95% deadwood and,
and I'm not being,
I'm believe me,
I'm not being snide about that.
It's no joke.
When you start to realize how much of what you've constructed of yourself is
based on deception and lies,
that is a horrifying realization.
And it can easily be 95% of you at your things.
You say things,
you act out,
you know it's well,
you see that in Pinocchio,
which I often you discussed.
You Know Pinocchio,
when he gets corrupt,
as he,
as he matures,
he first learns to lie and then he becomes a brain jackass on pleasure island.
It's like,
and he's threatened by the underground authoritarians,
right?
They're going to sell them to the salt mines.
It's like,
yeah,
that's for sure.
It's exactly right man.
So then you figure out you're a brain jackass and you're lying all the time.
That's a terrible realization.
And then all that needs to be burned away and know people don't like that.
You know?
Now you've been embattled in this conflict for quite a long time and I've got to
imagine that the way you look at the world,
the way you see things,
many,
many steps ahead.
Do you see any sort of a logical conclusion to this process?
Do you see any light at the end of the tunnel or do you see an impossible to
avoid conflict?
Like do you what?
What do you see when you look at this whole thing long term?
Well,
I would say I can't look at it long term.
And the reason for that is that,
and this is why I get a kick out of all the Keck Keka Stan Boys,
you know,
I do believe that we're in a period of chaos.
What's a Keck is tech.
Oh,
Keck is a mythological country that's ruled by chaos by the god Keck,
who's a frog.
The frog as it turns out.
Um,
so I don't know.
I don't know about those.
Oh,
well you need to look them up.
That's a big internet thing.
Keka Stan.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They Internet thing all know about the frog is the frog.
The Trump frog pepe the frog where they've,
who has apparently so distraught that has frog has been used to a lie on them
off a killed him off.
What?
Good luck.
He didn't.
All right.
So that's stupid because that's not who were,
um,
who were using pepe.
I haven't got the story quite right,
but I'll get it mostly right.
The people who were using peppy as a meme art is used.
Yeah.
That public of Keka staff,
they use this symbol,
k e k to replace lol.
And the reason they did that was because k e k in Korean means lol.
And so it was just this little joke.
Keck,
k.
E.
K.
Well then somebody found out these were people who were using pepe.
Remember it's a frog.
Then people found out that Keck was an Egyptian God and he was a frog and he was
between categories,
sort of like a transsexual by the way.
He was between categories and so now they have this republic of Keck and it's
ruled by this Egyptian God whose name is Ken,
who's a frog.
Hold on,
go back,
go.
They'll keep changing this.
Jamie's doing this in the background while you're talking,
but look at this.
There's a frog with a make America great again hat and he's got like a
tombstone.
It says those who served in the meme war 2015 and 2016 we are the gods of the
great meme.
More we are the shit posters,
the legion of Keck.
We are the Internet,
the death of the normies lulls and CAC.
We are one way or the fuck is going on that.
That is the question and that's the question you asked me and my answer was,
I don't know.
We're in a period of chaos.
We were in a period of chaos and in a period of chaos,
the time horizon shrinks because no,
because the outcome is uncertain.
Well,
this seems to be truly embracing chaos.
I mean just that statement,
the frog,
the Donald Trump thing with the hat on this.
See this is one of the things it seems to me to be a reoccurring feature in this
whole,
uh,
chaos ballet that we're watching play out is that people are enjoying the fact
that Donald Trump sucks as a president.
They don't feel threatened by it.
They like it and they don't don't like it because they want to burn this
motherfucker to the ground and towards this thing and like a Phoenix,
we will arise from the fire.
No,
no,
it's not that.
It's that they,
they are enjoying that.
It's falling apart.
This is why the we are the shit posters.
Do you know what shit posting is?
Yeah.
Jamie explained shit posting.
You're really good explaining it.
Posting for like literally no reason other than to get someone mad.
That's almost like trolling,
but it's like a separate level of trolling.
Right?
It's a good way to say it.
Yeah.
That's a good way.
It's a provocation for its own sake.
Jamie's the first person to tell me about shit posting.
I wasn't aware until about what a year ago.
Yeah.
I think it was.
Better about preelection time did not know.
So,
I mean there's rules for operating in chaos,
right?
Cause that's when you're in the belly of the beast or the belly of the whale and
you're underwater,
you're in the underworld,
you're in underworld,
in chaos.
And so that's a really cool thing to know Joe.
So imagine that the,
the normal world of mankind is inside that dominance hierarchy where everything
is going well because nothing abnormal is happening and you're getting what you
need and you want and you're conscious knowledge suffices.
Right?
Okay.
But then something tilts and that structure no longer works.
So where do you up?
He ended up in underworld.
That's what happens when your partner of 20 years has,
uh,
has a long term affair and you find out about it.
It's like you thought you knew where you were but you didn't.
And now that you found out you don't where you are,
but when you don't know where you are,
you're in the underworld.
Right.
And that's where the unconscious forces play.
Those are the gods.
It's why there's God's in the underworld and people go to the underworld all the
time.
It's chaos and fear and depression,
hopelessness and imaginativeness.
It's everything.
It's KLM is terrifying to people.
Terrifying and promising.
Cause dragons have gold because it's always,
the unknown has two things.
Just like the future.
It's like look out,
it'll do you in and look out.
It offers everything to you.
That's the underworld.
That's why the hero always goes into the underworld to find a cave full of gold.
It's true.
Guarded by a dragon in the hobbit.
Literally.
That's Bill Wolfe flight.
That's the oldest story of mankind.
It's really the our oldest story.
Wow.
And so that the underworld is chaos.
It's chaos.
And down there there's all sorts of play of possibility.
And the reason the frog was the was the guardian of chaos is because of the,
the frog is this thing that doesn't fit into categories.
You see,
because it's partly water.
It's partly land.
It's tadpole,
yet it's,
it's adult,
right?
So it's like a fish and then it's like an animal.
It doesn't fit.
And it's things that don't fit that blow apart the categories,
right?
Well that's what the transsexuals,
due to the category of gender for example.
And that puts you in this state of chaos.
It puts you in this state of chaos.
And that's what we're in now.
We're in a state of chaos.
And so what are the rules for operating in a state of chaos?
But as far as I can tell,
the fundamental rule when operating in chaos is tell the truth.
So for example,
if you went for the people that want to navigate this successful,
Yup.
All you've got,
that's what you've got as a,
as a shield and a weapon and,
and uh,
and that,
that's the guidepost.
That's the,
that's the way through.
Well,
and you see that and hero stories all the time,
you know,
so it's,
it's a lot.
Its allegiance to the truth,
but the truth is a strange thing.
It's a very strange thing.
Often the hero in a,
in his story has to assimilate their dark side before they're capable of telling
the truth.
Right?
In the Hobbit,
for example,
he has to become a thief,
right?
Because he has to get tough.
That's the thing.
Also,
the thing about telling the truth is that it's not for,
it's not for the naive,
not at all.
And partly because it burns off deadwood.
It's partly because it hurts people's feelings.
It's a sword.
So you have to be a warrior.
Wow.
A truth warrior
in this time of chaos,
right.
What emerges from this,
right?
Sometimes,
sometimes it's catastrophe.
That's the thing about these categories.
They're real,
they're real.
And you know,
the optimists that I hear say,
well,
depending on them swings and then it swings back and I think,
yeah,
well sometimes it,
it takes a hundred years to swing back and it takes a hell of a lot of people
out on the way and it never swings back at all.
So,
you know,
sometimes people go out to fight a dragon and it just eats them or it burns
them.
And that's the end of that.
Right.
And like we're in an unstable period of time at the moment in a transition
period of some sort.
I can't put my finger on it,
but I know that that's partly why what I've been saying has been resonating with
people,
because obviously it's not about pronouns.
Well,
it is.
It is,
except
language turns out to be about a lot more than like,
you can't take a little thing like the desire to transform pronouns and think
that that's a little thing.